it's been a bit but Brennan finally
started saying things that we needed to
start listening to again just because
he's an idiot not because it's important
he's going to tell us about Dana White
is he stealing the design stuff from the
website you were showing me yes too fat
to fit looks exactly like it and they've
been around for like 10 years
and he's just stealing it he steals
everything he doesn't care by the way
he's wearing unironically wearing a
supreme hat you see that right oh God
you saw it right ironically
anyway
boy you're also have a field day with
Dana stuff right he's like
is that you no okay took the high road
on that so he the way he described it
was I didn't hear it do you think you
took your high road yeah I mean he
definitely pointed out some stuff but
for the most part he could have went
hard like hardcore on Dana like one of
the things I think he would understand I
did this first
oh you're a producer
yes yes to that you would feel is when
Dana said like when Ariel was crying
about the whole making fun of him with
Jim Norton uh are you fun for crying and
it was saying what would your kids think
yeah and I'm like dude you anyone who
has kids would be like what the [ __ ]
uh I have no issue with Dana going out
I'm like me and Dana don't have the beef
that Dana and Ariel have no no you and
Dana don't have the beef because you're
not on the same level yeah see
here's the thing if Dana had beef with
Rogan that would be a thing right
because they are in my mind on the same
level right that has beef with Ariel
helwani because he has actual pull in
the MMA World exactly you're literally
nobody but wait till he sees why not I
heard a little bit of this wait through
his explanation like Ariel's in that
business he's a journalist right like
I'm more of an Entertainer so
he's more of an Entertainer he is he's a
comedic genius well you're entertaining
Papa who's who is ever [ __ ] doubted
his genius
I'm not a journal the [ __ ] doctor that
started to study his [ __ ] brain
at the same time oh your big was playing
your life that guy's like oh actually I
went to Baylor hi my name is uh Brian Wu
I'm a doctor
so I don't need credentials I'm not
trying to work at ESPN I'm not trying to
you know work on UFC now or the The
Fight Pass you know at the time he was
with us because they don't want you
there it's not because if because if
anything else you think of ESPN were to
come and said hey you want to do but he
wouldn't be there in a heartbeat oh God
ESPN well when Dana's also at the same
network he's gonna have a lot of control
and say of what you can and can't do and
Dana really made his life tough man so
there's Dana absolutely like if Dana's
hateless I would you know the guy who
tried blackmail him for the for the you
know the sex videos probably one a
Aerials one B I would assume I'm
probably fourth or fifth you are not
why does he think that because he took
one shot joking at him he needs to think
he's part he needs to present to people
like I'm part of this mix I'm in the mix
I hate to break it to you Brandon but
you're here with us you're not up there
with them you're in the mud with us you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and that's an ego thing I bet I'm not in
fourth or fifth I bet I'm more like nine
and ten on that list but I have no
resentment towards early or Dana in any
facet but when I see Ariel bringing it
up
um yeah yeah what'd you think was gonna
happen Dana and then Ariel has a big
voice he's like yo what do you think is
gonna happen man you made that kid's
life miserable Mr he's brought this
delight miss out on opportunities money
like mess with the guy's career man he
has kids and that's the way he feeds his
family yeah dude and you want to mess up
like this what do you think he was going
to do
you shoulda ran it by me don't but don't
do that I hate that one that's my one
that I hate the most
you know
um my thing is on it
I'm more I I don't know how to explain
it um because of the CTE it's probably
why
the neurons were being blocked very big
part of that would be probably yeah
unfortunately more just baffled that's
not a bigger story it's just it's
mind-blowing to me I don't want him to
lose his job or get fired but there
should be do you understand if they were
to
put his brain through a TSA scanner they
pull it aside for extra screening
because they think it was smuggling
things in it because while the black
spots
be swabbing it for explosives be
schwabbing it for explosions
you could have an explosive in it his
last special
[Laughter]
repercussions five takes it's a hit in
your wife and my there's but she hit him
first I'm sorry but I gotta be I gotta
I'm sorry but here's the thing I ain't
sipping for Dane in any way she hit him
first she hit him first
thing to that is
if you do that in a public place why
Dana's at a Senior Frogs I have no clue
why do you wear [ __ ] skinny jeans
what are you trying to [ __ ] opening acts
in your [ __ ] F-150 Raptor
um I don't know what it was like
basically a Senior Frogs but if you're
able to I don't drunk any drug you're on
I don't care I don't drunk any drugs
you're on I don't yeah I don't care any
drugs I don't drunk any drugs you're on
guys no matter what you drunk
if you're able to do that
in public around friends and family
you think that's the first time it's
happened come on if you can do that in
public come on man
maybe it's yeah how many times she hit
him I have some issues they need to
figure out oh [ __ ] how long you've known
her I don't [ __ ] she hit you first you
know it's just
not the way we work in society so I
think I'm what does that mean you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
just more blown away that the the ESPN
will do coverage of a soccer coach who
kicked his wife 30 years ago when he was
18 and you know whatever kicked in the
leg and that was the narrative on top
the Hamlin story and then Dana's the
face
but she hit him first yeah if it was two
guys this wouldn't be a story right
Vince McMahon allegedly grabbed graped a
bunch of women and he got away with it
he's back the biggest fight organization
in the world and under your umbrella and
there's not a mention I'm just awesome
I'm just like let's be honest he barely
Hit that [ __ ] Dana White's a big
[ __ ] he couldn't knock it he
just gave her a little slap stop oh wow
and
I I just unbelievable with this guy
ESPN's you know pretty far left
let's take a little break from me
chatting your ear off about the
fisticuffs Tampa I will see you January
20th and
scared no let's see wow someone's a
little scared chatting your ear off
about the fisticuffs Tampa I will see
you January 20th and 21st Tampa Bay
improv baby
might be a funny show why wouldn't you
want to go
mercenous and like jokes about Mexican
food I'll do it you will no do it not
you I'll do it do it come get your
tickets right now at fatkz.com or
thickboy.com
after that I'm in Springfield Missouri
that is February 3rd through the 5th so
make sure you get your tickets for
Springfield Missouri Naples February
16th through the 18th bakersfields one
night
all right anyway that was his advice to
Dina we don't have to play anymore this
[ __ ] dummy but um
foreign